this density in islahia is now home to
hundreds of Syrian families
is a mother of four who has to find a
way to provide for her children
her mother who lived in islahi as well
died in the earthquakes
is beyond words in my 27 years of life
I've never seen something like this it
was rainy and snowy when the earthquake
started we were panicking we barely
could leave the house we got some
blankets for the kids to keep them warm
one million of nearly 4 million Syrian
refugees living in Turkey are in the
province of gaziano
many of those who escaped the Syrian
Civil War have spent more than four
years in refugee camps in Turkey some of
them later built modest homes and some
rented them out but many are now back
where they started more than a decade of
Civil War has killed or displaced many
syrians millions of them fell out to
Turkey are looking for safety it wasn't
easy to begin a new life now the
earthquakes have taken what they built
here in the year since and they will
have to start from scratch this is what
is left of ipt Sam's father's house
was trapped under the rubble for hours
when he was pulled out he joined
Rescuers to save his wife
I'm waiting for the situation to calm
down I don't know what to do yet I might
go back to Syria I can't handle the life
here anymore I wish there wasn't war in
Syria I have 3 000 citrus trees there I
would go back if it wasn't for war
according to the Syrian Justice Center
in Istanbul more syrians died in the
earthquakes here in Turkey than in Syria
itself in the past two weeks hundreds of
bodies have been sent back to Syria from
gilvegas a border crossing to be buried
in their home country and thousands of
syrians have crossed the border to
attend the funerals of their relatives
Ali khabib is one of them
I'm going to Syria to perform my final
Duty for my sister she died in the
earthquake there her two children also
died I don't want her husband to mourn
alone but for those who survived like
many in distant City the future remains
uncertain
foreign